[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[За підтримки ЛАВКА ТРАДИЦІЙ
продукти від маленьких господарств]
[Мильчиці,
Галичина]
Наша сімейна сироварня називається
«Гарбузовий рай».
Вже рік часу ми тут займаємось сироварінням,
виготовленням джемів, а також приймаємо людей.
[Ігор Рева
Засновник сироварні]
Ми проводимо дитячі майстер-класи
і загалом насолоджуємось процесом — кайфуємо.
В нас було дві собаки.
Ми жили в однокімнатній квартирі в центрі Львова.
І в нас намічалася дитина.
А переїхати за місто ми вже давно хотіли.
І ми швиденько продали квартиру,
придбали недобудований будинок.
І 31 грудня, саме на Новий рік,
переїхали вже в свій новий будинок.
[Соломія Братах
Засновниця сироварні]
Насправді наша назва не має
нічого спільного з гарбузами.
Нашого старшого песика звати Гарбузик.
І ось цей момент, коли він провів у місті все життя,
звик гуляти на повідку.
І тут ми приїжджаємо, випускаємо його з машини
і він розуміє – там курочка,
там качечка, там лисичка, там зайчик... [сміються]
І він всюди гасав, всюди бігав, і туди і сюди,
і не знав, що з ним робиться.
І ми розуміли, що це Гарбузовий рай.
Ми закохались в цю місцевість,
власне, через краєвиди.
Бо це вже починається передгір'я Карпат –
ріки і ліси, це дуже красива природа.
Тут і ставів шість чи сім є, це просто красиво.
Ми знаходимось в приміщенні старої
австро-угорської школи, 1870 року побудови.
Цьогоріч нашому приміщенню 150 років.
Там де ми зараз переробляємо молоко
– росли кущі і дерева.
А в підвалі був величезний сміттєзбірник.
На цій світлині – ми вже встановили вікна,
але ще даху немає.
А для даху ми скуповували по всьому
Городоцькому районі черепицю, невеличкими кількостями.
Потім це все чистили KARCHER-ом і вручну.
І тоді повністю відновлювали автентичність будівлі.
У нас було величезне бажання швидко
зняти оцю всю плісняву, стару штукатурку.
І відновити приміщення таким як воно було.
Забрати все зайве.
Тут видно [на світлинах], до речі, як я збиваю штукатурку.
А це Соломія в масці –
вона болгаркою зачищала цеглу.
Ми переїжджали з дому для того,
щоб розділити дім і роботу.
І менше працювати,
а більше часу проводити вдома.
Я не знаю, чи за цей рік щось змінилось [сміються].
Менше працювати ми не стали.
А вдома ми просто рідко буваємо.
Направду так, ми більше часу проводимо
тут [на сироварні], ніж вдома.
Але в будь-якому випадку,
рішення про дистанціювання роботи від дому —
це рішення було надзвичайно правильним.
Коли ми вдома варили сир,
ми вдень переробляли 150-200 літрів молока.
Просто на газовій плиті у великій посудині,
до речі – ось в цій.
Тут у нас «банячок» на 500 літрів,
зроблений київською фірмою.
З 500 літрів молока
у нас виходить від 50 до 75 кг сиру.
У нас така концепція,
що ми не використовуємо нічого, окрім:
молока, закваски, ферменту, солі і спецій.
В нас відсутня хімія, взагалі.
Тобто ми не використовуємо навіть
хлористий кальцій, наприклад.
Мій сир їдять мої діти.
Тому я таким же чином ставлюсь до того,
що сир, який я роблю, будуть їсти чиїсь діти.
Відповідно, ми не можемо дозволити собі
погану якість або сумнівну безпечність.
Загалом ми виготовляємо близько 10 видів сирів.
Від свіжих сирів, кисло-ферментних сирів
до напівтвердих-витриманих.
І навіть в нас є сири з пліснявою.
Маємо також сир для грилю — халуммі.
Зараз дуже популярний, особливо влітку.
Кисло-ферментних сирів у нас три види є.
Перший — це з орегано і базиліком ззовні,
а в середині ми даємо грецький горіх.
Другий — це в нас пірамідки.
Ззовні з копченою паприкою,
а всередині з тархуном (естрагоном).
І третій — класичний варіант, це чорний перець ззовні,
а всередині часничок.
Найгостріший і найбільш ходовий,
найбільше його люблять.
Це є сир з хорватським чорним трюфелем.
Ми їздимо в Хорватію. Маємо там знайомих фермерів,
які вирощують трюфелі.
Постійно купуємо в них.
Сир такий, що або дуже подобається,
або не подобається взагалі.
За рахунок того, що чорний трюфель
має свій специфічний смак і запах.
Ми не зустрічали ще людину,
яка б рівнодушно поставилась до чорного трюфеля:
або «так», або категоричне «ні».
Відповідно таке ставлення і до самого сиру.
Солодкі джеми до витриманих сирів,
або до сирів з пліснявою.
Перший – це чорниця з лавандою.
Ми варимо чорницю, додаємо нашу лаванду
і це дуже гарно йде до сиру.
Другий – це наш ексклюзив, наша терта ружа.
Ми маємо свої насадження троянд —
відповідно свої пелюстки.
Ми її перетираємо і потім додаємо
як додаток до сиру.
В кожного сировара, на кожній сироварні
є дуже багато факторів,
які впливають на основу сироваріння.
Починаючи від того, яке молоко, що їсть корова...
І дуже багато залежить від рук сировара.
Зараз ми його просушуємо.
Щоб воно не злиплось між собою.
І щоб остаточно сформувалась скоринка.
В сироварінні руки, а точніше чутливість,
тобто дотик, вологість, температура...
Воно все на пальцях.
Якщо ми вдягнемо рукавиці —
ми не будемо нічого з цього відчувати.
Ну в такий спосіб можна робити... Заводський сир.
Сироваріння як таке – це в мене хобі.
Ще мабуть з студентських часів.
Для мене це творчість.
Навіть коли не вдається.
Тобто за весь свій стаж сироваріння,
я перепсував десь близько 5 тонн молока.
Це за більш ніж 10 років.
Псування молока – воно приносило кайф.
– Я тебе підтримувала.
– Так, однозначно! [сміються]
Позавчора сусіди відкрили мені таємницю,
що вони думали, що я трішечки «не розумна»,
бо я з козами гуляла на повідку.
Сусіди взагалі говорять, що ми «ту-ту».
Бо ми замість бульби троянди посадили.
Троянди, це вже моя така... Манія напевне.
В мене бачення таке – якщо на свята
не має пампухів з трояндою (з ружою) – то нема свят.
Нюхайте.
Ті пелюстки перетираються
з цукром і лимонним соком.
Далі тісто намазується тертою ружею,
зверху труться яблука, заливається все збитим білком
І зверху ще затирається тістом.
Це теж рецепт моєї бабці.
Я пам'ятаю цей смак з раннього дитинства.
Не знаю, що ще додати! [сміється]
Це просто береш половину цього пляцка,
величезне літрову кружку чаю.
І ти поснідав, пообідав і повечеряв.
Коли ми переїхали зі Львова за місто,
Ігор ходив час від часу на рибалку.
Вся дорога від дому
до річки – суцільні зарості м'яти.
Ми почали досліджувати старовинні рецепти кухні
і знайшли, що з м'яти можна робити сироп.
Ми можемо використовувати його
не лише для сиру.
Ми можемо додавати його в чай,
в коктейлі, в будь-що.
Де хочемо відчути м'яту.
Власне от такі старі рецепти...
Та сама терта ружа...
Намагаємось, якось це «задекларувати»,
що це кулінарна спадщина Європи,
власне нашого регіону,
що так робили наші бабусі й дідусі.
І це важливо. Це важливо –
бо наші діти мають знати, чим пишатись.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисерка
Марія Теребух]
[Режисерка монтажу
Оля Балицька]
[Оператори
Олег Сологуб, Назар Назарчук, Устин Компанієць]
[Звукорежисерка
Анастасія Климова]
[Асистентка продюсерки
Наталія Вишинська]
[Субтритувальник
Олач Тедор]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]